here's shawn mcdermott talking about the
challenge that he's facing this week is
he gets his team ready is he going to be
facing patreon homes is he going to be
facing chad henne on sunday here's
mcdermott on that subject
they're so good with the weapons that
they have around around patrick
andy does such a good job they're well
coached
that we've got to prepare
for
[Music]
this system we've got to prepare for
both quarterbacks and that's why we've
got a lot of work to do this weekend
it really does have to prepare for both
quarterbacks because we're five days out
and we don't know that patrick mahomes
is going to get the appropriate
clearances from an independent
neurologist to play on sunday we don't
know about the toe injury the the chiefs
are downplaying it but yeah look you got
you got a cocktail of injuries now that
patrick mahomes is dealing with as he
tries to to get himself in position
where he can play on sunday you've got
to be ready for chad honey and that is
going to deplete your preparation the
good news is they've already faced
patrick mahomes earlier this year the
bad news is it didn't go too well for
the bills so at least they've got some
experience there but chad henny came in
and played well in relief of patrick
mahomes on sunday and it gives the bills
a lot to think about and a lot to
prepare for chris as they get ready to
face the chiefs and try to get back to
the super bowl for the first time since
1993. it definitely does i don't think
it's like
a huge difference though to where you're
just sitting here like whoa this is two
totally different offenses between
mahomes and henny right i don't think
the offense is gonna drastically change
yes it'll become a little bit more
conservative and balanced like we saw
last year with matt moore you know
really probably look a lot like the way
kansas city played buffalo earlier this
year kansas city ran the ball in that
game i think more than any other game
they played this season
so they'll have a good feel for what
kansas city does
as far as without my homes now preparing
for my homes is a whole different animal
you have to worry about
like different route combinations that
really you don't have to worry about
with a lot of quarterbacks or any
quarterbacks in football except three or
four they're not going to cause some of
those aggressive bombs people moving all
over the place type plays with chad
henny they might not call moving the
pocket plays nearly as much either so
those are things that you know will be
different but i don't think as far as
the routes you know the schemes i don't
think that's going to change a whole lot
mike and and the last thing i'll say
just is you know
i i think the toe thing that you bring
up that i got
in the end i will be shocked that
patrick mahomes isn't cleared
for a concussion protocol and doesn't
play this weekend just the total honesty
what we see throughout the year where it
goes i would be shocked if he got
cleared for concussion protocol and
playing on sunday but
i wouldn't be shocked if you told me he
woke up yesterday morning and the worst
thing on his body was his toe he wasn't
worried about his head he was sending
out woody tweets and things witty tweets
and things like that we heard andy reid
say he was good but that toe that's
another thing and the fact that they're
blowing that off so much to me too
i don't know it just looks like to me
like they're they're kind of playing coy
about it like oh he might not be able to
move the pocket and do those things
without the toe but we'd like you to
still prepare for that so the toe's not
a problem that's what i thought at least
yeah you know what i agree with you
there we saw how it was hampering him
during the game and and and as i've said
it maybe the the only positive from the
concussion is it got him off that floor
before any further damage was done to it
as he tried to exert and just ignore it
and just go about his business and you
know and anybody's ever had an injury
and tries to fight through it you're
running the risk of greater damage to it
so with the concussion issue chris i
asked the league yesterday if historical
data is available regarding how much
time someone misses when they have a
concussion because my clear recollection
is
you used to be shut down for a game if
you had a concussion and then that
changed and the league told me from 2015
to 2019 there were 29 quarterbacks who
were diagnosed with concussions the
median
time before clearance to return was
seven days which puts us right at the
the period of time that that patrick
holmes has until his next game the
question is will he be able to practice
will he be able to prepare not that he
needs to but
there's a reason why you practice
there's a reason why
you you go through the process of
getting ready for a game and we may get
a patrick holmes who isn't able to
practice at all this week isn't cleared
to practice at all this week it still is
a very
strange i've i keep watching that play
over and over again i know i was
watching it yesterday for any evidence
of a violation of the rules and you
could argue that mack wilson did lower
his helmet to initiate contact even
though that that foul is haphazardly
called by officials because it's so hard
to spot it in real time
but the rest of the play
was clean i mean none of it was dirty he
was a runner and a tackle was made right
but
but but the and look if i was patrick
mahomes dad i would disagree his mother
clearly disagrees and wanted mac wilson
ejected and i'd want to go fight mack
wilson and let mack wilson kick my ass
if uh if it it had been my son but but
still when you make him a runner when
you call a running play on third and one
with a guy who's got a bad toe you're
putting him in harm's way he's
potentially going to get hit and he's
potentially going to get hurt i still
don't see no what happened to him to
cause a concussion that's what continues
to vex me two days later i'm with you
there the one thing just watching film
on that game a little yesterday that
kind of came to me is what maybe it was
almost the twisting of the neck as he's
being brought to the ground like you
know how a boxer can you know the chin
just gets knocked a little bit and cuts
off that blood and oxygen to the brain
and all of a sudden you're you know on
cloud nine i did think of that because
the way he was tackled through the neck
there and then as he does hit the ground
his neck really does kind of get rolled
up a little bit in a weird awkward
position but i'm with you and i
certainly listen i i know mrs mahomes is
it's her baby boy and i understand that
and gosh i i'm glad i didn't have
twitter when i played this who knows
what my mom might have tweeted too but
but
you know
it's football that was nothing he's been
f-bombs he would have been fbi there
would have been an f-bomb sure but you
know
he wasn't trying to lead to the head
that that's where everything now has
become like oh did his head touch did
his head touch listen the head is
attached to the body when you even try
to hit with the shoulder there's a good
chance the head's going to touch it's
this big thing on top of the shoulders
it's hard to move it so like
i don't like this conversation about
this stuff every now and then like every
play like the sorensen dive in the end
zone then we're just gonna have to let
players dive in the end zone no more
tackling at the one-yard line i don't
know but sorry you got me off on this
and i just don't think that's the point
of that one
i'll never forget we were in florida for
the league meetings and they had 10
proposals that year for rule changes all
of a sudden they show up with a proposal
number 11 that was not previously
disclosed to the media that was just
distributed and it was already voted on
and passed and it is so broad that it is
a foul to lower your helmet to initiate
contact i mean what the hell
that happens all game right it happens
all remember all the consternation in
the preseason that year so the rule is
still on the books they expect guys to
adhere to it sometimes they throw the
flags sometimes they don't sometimes
they get it right sometimes they get it
wrong
it's a bad rule it's poorly conceived
it's poorly enforced but it ain't going
anywhere no because somebody got
convinced in that ballroom at the hotel
in florida a few years ago that this is
something they had to do regardless of
how nonsensical it may have been but you
know back to mahomes yeah i think you
may be on to something because andy reid
said after the game
that he had the wind knocked out i mean
as we all know that doesn't mean you
actually have the wind knocked out of
your lungs it means that something's
happened on your spinal cord to short
circuit right the the involuntary
operation of your lungs and your heart
and everything kind of skips a beat and
skips a breath and you got to recover
from that it may just be look i mean he
clearly looked like he had been right
right but you just you just wonder if
he'd stayed on the ground a little bit
longer maybe he would have been able to
get up and he would have seemed fine i
don't know none of us knows because he
got up quickly yeah but what what we do
know is he'll be checked thoroughly by
doctors there is a truly independent
neurologist it's not like it used to be
where if the doctor wants to continue to
provide services to the team the doctor
makes sure the players are available to
the team that's why they got independent
neurologists involved in this and uh
yeah i'd be surprised chris if he
doesn't play on sunday because we've
seen guys come back
over and over and over again within a
week after being concussed yeah right
right we've seen a lot of it you know
especially
like you said here in recent history the
last year or two i just feel like
marquee players that miss multiple games
because of concussions or even one game
i mean i feel like it's been you know
few and far between and the ones that
have missed those multiple games it's
been you know again i'm never trying to
judge anybody's hit or how they got hit
in the head but been a lot more
egregious you know blows to the head at
least as far as the way it looks on tv
and things like that than what we saw
there yesterday so you know he doesn't
need to practice as long as he can just
have a ball and throw the ball around
the field a little bit and have feel for
that he'll be able to go through the
mental aspects of the game him not
practicing might be a good thing just
like you just talked about with him
getting off his feet with his toe it
might just be good okay let the toe rest
for the whole week he'll be fresh and
ready to go on sunday but
man would that be like
the most debbie downer tease of all time
if we're about to get josh allen and
patrick mahomes in the afc championship
game and mahomes couldn't play i mean i
i'm i'm dead serious if i wake up sunday
morning and i read on pft that my homes
can't play i i might drop to my knees
and cry i'm not even joking like that
that'll be just heartbreaking uh so i i
really hope that's not the case
yeah and and you know what i i
what would you i'm good i'm gonna go
ahead and say it yeah because
the league needs him to play exactly yes
they do and and
and the i mean so the pressure that used
to apply to the team doctor right to
make the guy available at some level is
there pressure on the independent
neurologist now because the the broader
nfl structure needs patrick mahomes to
play i i'm just throwing that out there
i
mean
the mere fact that they have an
independent neurologist acknowledges
there is a conflict right team doctor is
there a conflict for the independent
neurologist right is there a is there an
independent neurologist who's been
living under the rock of somewhere and
doesn't realize how big this weekend is
and who patrick mahomes is i mean you
would have that would be
hard for me to think that he could like
okay wait this is one of the biggest
games of this guy's life it's the
championship weekend i live here in the
area i'm very aware and reading the news
and everything else like that that i
mean that's it's hard to be truly
independent there too and i also sit
there and go
you know this is where as a grown man
and you know you're your mid-20s you're
30 years old and you might feel good
on a saturday the day before the game if
they told you you couldn't play and you
just feel like you're functioning and
all that man that would be a hard pill
to swallow but that's another
conversation well it is another
conversation and i've had that
conversation before because there is
i think
you know how far do you go to protect
someone from themselves right at what
point is the person sufficiently lucid
and capable of making the conscious
decision that i will play i'll sign
whatever you want i understand i
understand i'm not completely and
totally cleared but i'm fine i've got my
wits about me i know what i'm doing i
know the risk i'm taking that that that
issue comes up from time to time and
it's just weird the longer we get
removed from 2009 when the nfl first had
its epiphany about concussions we've
gotten numb to it we've gotten used to
it and culturally there have been
changes made but there still is an
undeniable quality here where the human
being has to make the decision about
what he wants to do and i mean when he
walks out onto the field when he's
perfectly healthy he's accepting the
risk of a serious injury
at what point do you allow the player to
assume the risk that if he's not
completely 100 percent
but he's close enough where he can make
the decision when do you let him do it
so far the nfl has aired on the side of
saying no we're not going to let you
play so we'll see how that plays out
we'll see if it's an issue yeah if it is
it's going to be a hell of a story for
the weekend because it can be chad henny
versus josh allen not patrick mahomes
and i trust that josh allen would win a
throwing contest against chad henny not
sure who would win the throwing contest
between allen and mahomes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports